mischa barton was hospitalized Thursday  morning after local authorities  responded to a disturbance call at her  West Hollywood home TMZ was first to  report the news the 31 year old appeared  to be behaving bizarrely in her backyard  when authorities arrived and she was  voluntarily transported to a nearby  hospital for a mental evaluation  remember in 2009 mischa was placed on an  involuntary psychiatric hold and in 2013  she opened up to people about what she  called a full-on breakdown quote it was  terrifying straight out of Girl  Interrupted story of my life the star  explained that her parents attempted to  stage an intervention prior to the 2009  incident shortly after she was admitted  to a psychiatric ward when she  threatened to take her own life and two  years before that mischa was arrested  for a DUI and possession of marijuana  you